stephen there he is hello man in the  mirror i know you're scared a bit yeah i  know you're confused you weren't  supposed to see any of this  what are you sure you want to know  [Music]  [Applause]  mark you look different  i can't tell the difference  between my weights and knives  on dreams  am i like some sort of secret agent  it's a little more complicated than that  we protect the vulnerable  and deliver justice  this is the best worst day of my life  marvel studios moon night only on disney  plus  stephen  [Music]  what are you are you like living inside  of me it's a little more complicated  than that  mark you look different  [Music]  we protect the vulnerable  and deliver justice  [Music]  this is the best worst day of my life  marvel studios moon night only on disney  plus